jean marie
à mes yeux
si garbo bercy alors jean marais 13000
personnes
il est devenu le johnny hallyday de
l'humour parce qu à personne d'autre qui
fait ça quoi oui c'est venu comme ça je
n'ai pas voulu en plus je dis tout le
temps c'est le spectacle qui a poussé
les murs toi on vendait les places 6
mois non à la france
donc voilà ça c'est venu comme ça et
j'ai appris à jouer avec les écrans et
c'est devenu un nouveau port belge
voulait pas le faire à jean lé kom i
avec les imbéciles qui ne changent pas
d'avis je me suis rendu compte que que
c'était vachement bien il ya 80 mètres
que tout le monde côté cadre est comme
ça et puis que tu as deux écrans de 6
mètres sur huit personnes loupé une
mimique et tout le côté live tu l'as à
l'idée d'être derrière de voir toute une
salle se manger les genoux temps 20 ans
et tous et c'est très joli et donc voilà
ça s'est passé comme ça ça rend pas
mégalo banon mais après ça donne
vachement envie c'est un peu une drogue
dure parce que après quand il m'arrivait
de rejouer dans une salle de 2000 j y
tiens je suis dans ma loge sait où la
salle généreusement au point virgule
genre tout l'été avec 48 heures avant
j'ai fait le point virgule justement
pomme dégonflé la tête je suis dit je
vais faire exactement le même spectacle
dans la plus petite salle de paris 1 48
heures la plus petite et la plus grosse
soit 130 et 13 mai ce qui était génial
c'est que j'ai une équipe d'enfer et qui
ont ils m'ont mis des petites ils ont
tous trouvé dès que je leur ai donné
l'idée ils ont trouvé des petites varie
light
il y avait deux écrans de télé à la
place des écrans de l'internet sur huit
donc on a fait exactement la même chose
au point virgule est ce que c'est bon
pour la libido
ça fait ça fait guili guili partout y
compris dans le plexus génitales
c'est que tu que tu passes sur une bosse
avec une voiture cinq guides alors oui
oui cela fait un peu pareil c'est grave
il ya moins de buzz sur les routes là
c'est ça qui est derrière
avant c'était bien oui avant c'était
bien alors j'ai un autre mail clémence
tissi ni de marseille c'est la démence
un mail donc pour vous guider mes
copines ne veulent pas croire que la
fiche de ton spectacle n'est pas truquée
et et elles ne veulent pas croire que tu
as vraiment des couilles énorme dealer
la prochaine fois que tu passes à la
télé ces signes et la petitesse
oui eh bien écoutez il faut que je lui
dise que heins couché pas menti c'est
elle qui remet le paquet et bourg bercy
là on était sponsorisé par roland garros
alors jean marie bigard partout où il
passe
us de bons souvenirs beaucoup de mal
certain que je ne peux pas lire
évidemment à l'antenne vous vous en
doutez jamais paris rien pour moins de
mumu qui me dit j'aimerais que tu
rendent un hommage à toutes les femmes
qui aiment un mari qui n'est pas le leur
et qu'ils profitent de leur week-end en
solo pour se régaler devant tout le
monde en parle tous les samedis soir
voilà et ben ça c'est bien mais c'est un
hommage ton émission
oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
l'amour devant l'émission qui ça va oui
c'est dingue est tellement long puis au
bout d'un moment
voilà marie jo de la ville de nice qui
me dit c'est pas frustrant de savoir que
la moitié de la france envoie en l'air
pendant que toi tu l'os si c'est
frustrant
enfin bon non mais reconnaît qu on a
fumé de droit baguette club fait une
partie de tarot est tous vraiment un bel
arrêt c'est ce qui se passe oui entonné
durupt de précis du rut durupt qui me
dit j'ai fait empailler ma chatte parce
qu'elle bougeait par le single parce que
je dois dire aussi que j'ai reçu
beaucoup beaucoup de propositions depuis
que j'ai roulé une pelle à raphaël
mezrahi avait la langue j'ai vu cette
lan ông absolument non mais c'est
excitant pour que tu as fais ça tu étais
pas oublier ça j'ai bien banon avec
talent que c'est plus agréable figure
toi et là c'est quand il embrasse comme
ça comme il y est tu sens la barde
j'aimais ça y est c'est excitant
et si tu me tues mais tu es un doigt
dans le cul
alors non mais parce que ça va aller où
la prochaine fois je sais pas justement
ma mère ma mère est très en colère alors
par exemple geoffrey de nalinnes me dit
je suis un joli la forme maintenant je
suis un joli garçon et si tu es d'accord
je prends mon no 10 à 4 et je fonce
alors il dit mon style que star cravatée
classique mais je suis très
charismatique qu'elle savait rien et
coûte laisse-toi pénétré par l'idée
dans un premier temps vous voulez
rarement les faits le garçon nous
annoncée rarement tout cas pas avec la
langue
j'avais dit à des copains des fois
apparu ce la rue swing à la russe comme
ça aurait il faut mettre soi-même
jean-marie oui je vois bien que tu
insistes
tu me laisses le réfléchir un petit truc
à la femme les murs en fin d'émission
d'accord tu serais d'accord
éventuellement faut voir